super zoo is bringing the professional
pet community back together for the pet
industry's first live trade show in 2021
at the mandalay bay convention center we
have pet lifestyle expert stephanie
kroll here to give us a sneak peek at
what's new at this year's show catch us
up stephanie welcome back it's so
exciting to be back thanks for having me
of course of course let's go through the
let's go through the items here because
you know as the as the pandemic created
plenty of changes for the pet industry
i'm sure
we wanted to eat healthier and so do our
pets right yes and pet ownership surged
so it was great pet adoptions are up so
um you know people searching for
great new pet products so we have all
the answers here at super zoo well let's
go through them so one of the big things
is made in the usa when looking for a
pet food hound and gatsas is a top line
dog and cat food and they have super
foods in their food so that includes
cranberries blueberries broccoli
dandelion grass and all superfoods
that's what we try to find in our in the
shakes and the smoothies yeah
wow yeah wow and this is
yes it's great for digestion skin coat
so this is hounding down first
yeah first
yes
and then the other thing is you know
salmon is has so many health benefits so
this is a mega plus king salmon and this
is pure new zealand salmon king salmon
this is the salmon that you find in
restaurants so you can see this is
freeze-dried
and this is great treats and it's
freeze-dried to make it easy
you know
training treats you know when they're
being a good boy good girl and they also
have a salmon oil okay i know my mom is
watching i hope you're taking notes
because rj needs all of this here
and speaking of delicious seafood we
have tuna bites so this is from snip
snap and it's just great uh essential
vitamins in here and some rosemary
extract as well okay and is that for
dogs are all pets yes
and then also we have charlie bear
banola bites so you can actually try one
that's granola clusters
because what's in it it's just delicious
they have a pumpkin spice flavor
blueberry pie
it's just granola oh it was literally
just granola yeah i was hungry this
morning this is my breakfast oh my god
how cute so i could just hang out with
rj and eat granola with yeah definitely
i love that perfect for snuggling
all right let's move on here another
thing is um treatables so mobility a lot
of pet owners are looking for things to
help with joint pain or
even if your your pet doesn't want to
take a pill you just fold it up here in
the treatables
there's
pure hemp seed oil so it makes it really
easy to digest and you put the pill in
there or it's a great great treat that
is from treatable it's a great line i'm
sorry we have to wrap but how can people
get into how can people join the super
zoo super zoo this is just close to the
experts you're going to be seeing this
on the show floor and the other thing a
lot of these companies are sustainable
so just like sustainably yours it's a
pure
cat litter made of corn and cassava so
just the innovation at super zoo is
great well thank you for all of your
expertise this is amazing jc i'll send
it over to you you want some granola
save the treats absolutely i got you
jasmine love that